We absolutely must go over a bizarre and
embarrassing interview given yesterday to Fox
News by former President Donald Trump. And it was
humiliating and embarrassing, not just for Trump,
but also for Fox News, which in the middle of the
interview falsely reported the resignation of Joe
Biden, secretary of Homeland Security, just they
just reported it in the middle of the interview
with Trump, then had to walk it back after Trump
had already reacted to it. So let's get into it.
Donald Trump kicked the interview off with really
similar rhetoric about immigrants to that of his
infamous 2015 speech about Mexicans. A lot of this
vocabulary will probably sound familiar to you
bringing the violence to our country, because many
of the people coming are not nonviolent people.
They're violent people. Many of the people coming
to these countries don't send out their finest.
And in some cases, I'm sure you have a wonderful
fine people. But you also have criminals, you have
murderers, you have sex traffickers. You have a
lot of very bad people coming into our country.
The theme in this
interview was
Trump saying ridiculous things with no pushback
whatsoever from interviewer Harris Faulkner.
Here's another example where, again, Donald Trump
continues to say he actually won, not Joe Biden.
Harris Faulkner just accepts it. No big deal
policies. And even, you know, I was well,
I mean, look, we won the election as far as I'm
concerned. We had a great election. We got almost
75 million votes. But we were going to make
it even more stringent with the understanding
that we want people to come into our country,
but they have to come in legally. Very simple.
So let me let me ask you this. I want to get back
a moment and revisit the covid-19, because that
just no pushback at all from Faulkner,
despite the fact that Donald Trump is
saying something completely, verifiably,
empirically untrue. She just moved on.
Then Donald Trump makes false claims about
Joe Biden's policy at the border. Again,
no pushback from Harris Faulkner whatsoever.
Oh, I mean, it was just announced they're
allowing everybody to walk through and just
come in and they're not taking anything.
They have no information about the people.
And then we get to arguably the most surreal
moment of the interview, other than
when Trump said, I don't know why I'm
here. You really called me. We'll get to that.
Harris Faulkner interrupts and falsely reports
live on air that the secretary of the Department
of Homeland Security, Alejandro Mayorkas,
has resigned. Trump says, well, I'm not surprised
to hear that because things are so bad at the
border. And then Harris Faulkner says, oh, that
that actually didn't happen. Take a look at this.
This because it's just happened now. And I
want to double check this with our producers.
The DHS secretary, Alejandro
Mayorkas, has resigned. Mr. President,
I'm not surprised. Good. That's
a big victory for our country.
Hold on. Let me let let me stop. Let me
stop. Let me listen to my team one more time.
Forgive me. Forgive me, that has not happened,
but I apologize for listening to the
team, and I know that you.
Where do they even get that literal fake
news being reported live on Fox News? And
maybe that warrants more more discussion
on its own. Trump than hilariously says
Joe Biden isn't being transparent.
What do you say about the transparency
with the current administration?
Well, there is none. There is none.
Remember, Trump promised his tax returns six
years ago. Never release them. Trump promised
to drain the swamp. He didn't. Trump lied
about what he privately knew about covid.
I could go on and on and on. But Trump says
Biden isn't being transparent. And then
Donald Trump is asked, why are you choosing to
weigh in so strongly? And he just sort of says,
I don't know. You guys called me really.
Most presidents, ex presidents like yourself
do not weigh in at this level. Why did
you feel like you needed to on this issue?
Well, you called me I didn't call you, in
all fairness, but the reason I weigh in
with the statement last night,
it was what I wrote a
statement. I put out a statement that
so an irritated sounding Trump there always
just so strange. And then Donald Trump starts to
wrap up the interview by saying that China is,
quote, looking at woak. That's pretty unusual
terminology. China's looking at WOAK. And then
he says Manono know something about Dr. Seuss,
which nobody has ever seen before in order to
accomplish the Green New Deal nonsense. They're
destroying it with WOAK. When China looks at work
and they see the biggest problem we have is Dr.
Seuss. In the meantime, they're building factories
and trying to kill us in so many different
ways. They laugh at us. They think we're so
frankly, they think our country is stupid when
they look at this, when our competitors look at
what's going on in our country, taking down the
statues to great heroes and so many other things.
Now I do it because I want to do what's
right and they are destroying our country.
Isn't that truly something China is going
to be building factories and trying to kill
us. So Donald Trump trying to rehab his greatest
hits, essentially, while at the same time telling
more lies, mixed in with a false resignation
report from Fox News in the middle of it,
having to almost immediately be walked back. I
mean, this is the epitome of the Trump interview.
Trump won't stop lying. Interviewer
won't question any of the lies,
but reports her own literal fake news in the
middle of the interview will have more on this
interview because it was so wacky and wide
ranging